"Spider-Man: Across the Spider-Verse" has
received rave reviews, but some fans aren't
happy about one particular aspect of the film.
It goes without saying that "Spider-Man: Across
the Spider-Verse" is one of the most anticipated
films of 2023.
It's the follow-up to the Oscar-winning "Spider-Man:
Into the Spider-Verse" that's been five years
in the making.
It has quite a legacy to live up to, and if
reviews are any indication, it's soaring over
most people's expectations.
The animation is top-notch, and it takes the
characters in a darker, more mature direction
with a plot that places the fate of the entire
multiverse at stake.
However, it appears there's at least one thing
that's dampening people's enjoyment of the
film in theaters.
Numerous online threads have emerged of viewers
discussing how the sound mix felt off, at
least at the beginning of the movie.
In the official "Across the Spider-Verse"
discussion thread on Reddit, many people chimed
in, implying this is a nationwide issue that
isn't localized to just a couple of theaters.
For instance, one redditor wrote,
"Did anyone else's theater have sound mixing
too low for characters compared to the music?
Other than that, this movie was an absolute
treat."
"My name is Miles Morales.
I'm Spider-Man."
Other people chimed in, saying they noticed
it during the opening sequence, which features
a voiceover from Gwen Stacy while rhythmic
drumming plays.
Apparently, the music's so loud it's difficult
to make out anything Gwen says, to the point
where people are already looking forward to
the home release so that they can rewatch
the scene with subtitles.
Reddit isn't the only place where Spidey fans
are voicing their frustration.
Similar comments have emerged on Twitter as
well as a thread on ResetEra, and it would
appear the people behind the movie have become
well aware of the situation.
"Across the Spider-Verse" writer and producer
Phil Lord tweeted some pictures of stickers
he had made up to send to movie theater projectionists
that read:
"I played Spider-Verse at full volume because
I'm awesome."
He went on to explain,
"The movie mix is really dynamic and comfortable
at full volume.
In a full house it might even be better at
7.5!"
It would appear not everyone has received
the memo yet, as plenty of people commented
underneath Lord's post to talk about their
audio mix issues.
The common complaint is that the dialogue
is too quiet when the film starts and gets
drowned out by the music, and it seems to
be a recurring issue regardless of what format
people see it in.
"What?"
"Oooo, okay."
Some theater employees mentioned how they
would abide by Lord's guidelines, but it may
take others some time to receive word.
That means fans who saw it last night may
have had issues with the film that those who
plan on seeing it in a week or two won't experience.
Not being able to hear what Gwen's saying
at the beginning of "Across the Spider-Verse"
can be cumbersome, but it's clear most fans
love this movie regardless.
The film currently has a 95% positive rating
from critics on Rotten Tomatoes, and people
can't stop raving about it on Twitter.
Under Phil Lord's tweet, fans discussed their
personal experiences with the audio mix, but
many were quick to remind him that the film
is fantastic.
One person even tweeted,
"It was too quiet in my theater tonight.
Guess I'll have to go see it again.
And again.
And again."
On top of that, the film is such a visual
spectacle that even scenes of just two characters
talking are incredibly fun to watch.
It makes sense there are people who pointed
out the audio issues but also argued that
they came secondary to everything else.
One person wrote on Reddit,
"Eventually I stopped paying attention to
that because the movie sucked me in."
Hopefully, projectionists get word of the
best settings to use for the film's audio.
But if they don't, it seems like people will
still have a good time.
"Spider-Man: Across the Spider-Verse" is playing
in theaters right now.